how's it going
and welcome to if not Friday we're gonna
do it anyway and I'm doing it outside
because I'm my lightning broke and it's
looks like it's gonna start raining soon
we gotta hurry all right so
first of all I just want to say thank
you bros so much 49.5 brett cars for
9.50 via bros i can't tell you enough
how much that means to me that so many
of you are keep popping in so many of
you are sticking around and enjoying
what i do i that but really makes me
happy
it's an incredible number and i never
thought we would reach it so i'm just
living the dream bye bye thanks to your
breasts I wanted to do something that we
haven't done in a long time which is a
Q&A an actual Q&A I know I do it'd be
doing a lot of next question and there's
is everything I asked you Bruce on
Twitter to ask me questions and
literally 99% of them was like to do
something with a banana so I guess
that's what you bros are into huh great
but I wanted to do a normal Q&A where i
answer actual questions I know it's I
know it's weird right and it's been a
while so it let's do it
first question is from beard of that
great name
you have great tasting names I gotta
hand it to you when are you moving to a
place with better internet we're
actually moving the 2nd of July to
Brighton we're moving to the UK me and
my staff for three months for the summer
we're just we want to have our own place
and we want to have a place with proper
internet as some of you bros know I live
in Italy and they have really bad
internet some videos take me over 25
hours to upload which is 25 hours too
many it should not take an ear that long
and I cannot get better internet from
where we are so we're moving to UK we
always wanted to stay there so we're
gonna try it out and we'll see if we
like it ah Natalie Scott scatter elbow
that's
do you ever read fanfiction made for you
on Debian art anymore while other ways
you still try to connect with Bros
honestly sorry for laughing but you seem
seem a little down
Natalie I don't know I don't know why
first of all I I don't read fanfiction I
think why would I know I don't get a
kick out of it or anything like that if
that's what you think and I never
claimed that write fanfiction either so
I don't know I don't know where you're
coming from with this skeptism but this
one thing that I haven't changed during
the years is that I always try to
connect with you bros I still answer as
many messages as I can Twitter Facebook
private messages anything you know
that's something that I really enjoy
doing and that makes me feel part of you
bros and I I I always want to have that
connection with bros i hope i always
even though i can't answer every single
message like ice I used to I still want
to do my best at doing it and I think
you both realized that I can't answer
all of them and I hope I hope you bros
still understand and appreciate it bye
Carmichael why didn't you make the last
week Friday's good Peter back last week
we had a midsummer party here and
basically midsummer is a holiday in
Sweden where we bends as frogs and drunk
I can't be making videos every single
day of the year I'm sorry is this going
to be on an actual fright no same reason
like I do everything by myself I it
takes a lot of time to make videos on a
daily basis sometimes I just have to
postpone it
I'm sorry okay I hope you both realize I
I feel like it's a running joke that
these are never actually up on a Friday
I know it
hello a lot of us wanted me to rename it
to break-ins see it doesn't even sound
good it's gonna be Friday loop advice
thing okay Megan if you weren't famous
this I don't like that word if you're in
bah-bah-bah would you be subscribed to
your own channel
yes I think so I think it would be
really exciting to be part of all the
growth that is going on and has been
growing on to see see see see that I've
been doing that with some other
youtubers that have been really popular
after a while and it's it's fun exciting
to be a supporter of that and I think I
would really appreciate that
I would I would probably be really
jealous of myself because I know that's
who I am I'd be like I wish I was doing
that and stuff like that I don't know
I'd be a bro of course I'd be the
ultimate bro
the biggest bro ever bro bro if you
weren't making videos for us what would
you be doing
I've probably finished off my master
degree in Industrial Management and
economy which was what I studied before
and but it would be something that I
didn't enjoy doing and I think that's
that's the main reason why I'm so glad
that YouTube worked out and like even if
I wasn't making videos now I've learned
that I should you should really follow
your heart and you should do what you
want to do and what you are passionate
about it I really it's hard for me to
talk about this but I really was wasn't
happy before because I it felt like I
didn't enjoy what I was doing and it
felt like it didn't have a purpose of me
doing it so the future for me was
something really like I didn't even want
to think about it
I've learned I learned a lot from this
YouTube about myself and that I always
no matter what I want to do what I what
I love to do and what I'm passionate
about and I hope I can carry that
message on to you Bros that I'm not
saying school or anything like that
but you should definitely follow what
you want to do absolutely life is too
short for doing things that you don't
like oh yeah I'd probably be a
professional ballerina well how did you
come to the idea to call your
subscribers browse it was actually in
amnesia I used to call the monster like
bro
I'd be like Jersey Shore I'd be like hey
bro what you doin bro come at me bro
that was actually a running joke for a
while that didn't survive one of the few
ones that do it but I guess technically
it did because you bros are the monster
in that Nisha that's that's it you
didn't know that that's how I see you
aren't you bros what so that's it I know
a lot of a lot of wanted to call like
girls bro bro ants but I think we're all
bros here
it doesn't matter bout a gender Joe
broke bros and more than just gender yes
I guess did you ever think that you
would get this far there like a lot of
these questions are hyping me get this
far on YouTube to have over 8 million
bro sales
thanks I will try no of course not I
don't think anyone could anticipate
something like this it's been crazy I
literally was excited when I hit 30
subscribers like I remember that mark I
was like yeah 30 I'm the man but I
still feel that feeling like god it's
still like exciting that it's growing
it's tough like that and I think that's
what's important but I've never ever
ever and I'm a big dreamer too like I
usually think like ha what if it gets
this big or whatever but never ever
near this I feel I feel really honored
and I feel really privileged to be where
I am and I know it's thanks to your
brother hey you can take that what
everywhere you like have you ever
considered changing your current
hairstyle to a more funky r1 what the
hell is wrong with my hairstyle it's not
funky enough for you huh this is not
funky enough for you huh I think it's
pretty damn spunky you just show me your
hair kind of tell me how funky it is you
wanted me to I don't know no I guess
what do you expect your life to be in
ten years professional ballerina just
make it happen Russ what made you want
to make youtube videos I'm curious by
the way you're awesome you're off I
remember it wasn't YouTube that made me
wanna make youtube videos I knew I
wanted to make gaming videos even know
before I knew about YouTube the whole
idea
to me that you could record yourself
playing a game was just I don't know I
knew I wanted to do it and I actually
plan it for a long time before I
actually bit it like I probably planned
on making it for two years but I wanted
to have the right hardware and stuff
like that so he wouldn't look crappy and
stuff like that but yeah Anabelle
sterling do you believe in ghosts no I
don't I'm really like I believe very few
things but I'm I'm not like if someone
else believes in art like if you really
go such that's okay good night but I
find it hard to believe and it doesn't
really scare me either I know if my
sight would show up and scare me I would
be God because apparently that's my
natural-born gift to get scared if so
what if something is if something jumps
at me I'll get scared but if I go alone
in the dark
it's not the same it doesn't scare me
the same way
I've actually realize that
I got it from my dad my scared Ness it
was a we're at a holiday in Florida six
months ago and we were in an elevator
and my dad had his back turned to the
door and he turned around and the door
opened that was tiny little girl that it
wasn't scary at all but it caught him
off guard and he was like whoa and he
nearly fell and that's when I knew that
this YouTube thing this gift of being
scared of jump scares come from my dad
my dad's it's pretty funny though if you
could be a Disney Princess who would you
be and why that's a great question it's
a very close to my heart question I want
to be out the Little Mermaid because
then I could swim in the sea and then if
someone kissed me I could become a
prince there's no good answer to this I
want to be them all okay don't judge
Jake Bauer did you enjoy the last one
yes it was fantastic game I loved it
sweet I hope you both liked it too I'm
sad it's over though I'm gonna miss it
how do you record each day and how long
does it usually take to edit a video the
recording part is very little compared
to everything else like the managing the
channel and editing that's what really
takes a lot of time I used I used to put
like 12 hours a day and for a long time
in everything but I'm trying to I'm
trying to slow that down a little bit
I'm doing two videos a day now instead
for example there's more to life than
just
making videos I guess even though I love
doing it so for me sitting two hours a
day doing this no problem I love doing
it so I don't really care what are your
favorite flavors of ice cream and will
you be my best friend
you have beautiful glasses so of course
on your best friend stretch atella
is my favorite you know during winter
when there's like the snow and they put
the tiny rocks in the end of the snow so
it looks it kind of looks like special
fella and I'm like mmm I don't want to
eat it but that would be a bad idea
but it's still my favorite ice cream
best answer ever do you plan on playing
games for the rest of your young life or
are you gonna find something new after
web by professional ballerina no I think
I will keep making videos as long as
it's fun for me I am like I said it's
really important for me that I still
feel like it's a hobby and not a job
even though I do put a lot of time into
it I'm going there like I could get an
editor and I could get some help with
different production and stuff like that
but I I'm still the one doing everything
but by myself and I wanted to keep it
that way and I want that to be kind of
like an inspiration for for you bros
maybe I wanted to you bros to feel like
hey if pills can do it I can do it so if
you have any dream or hopes out there
you can just be like well if pills can
do it I can do it cuz I I don't know I
like to be more proud of myself than
being proud what I got help doing I
guess
know what is the secret of your success
all these questions are just here to
hide the out of me I want to call
it success
I'd say luck or anything I don't know
but I don't know I guess I really put my
heart and soul into making videos and I
think that's something that I know for
sure is necessary if if if I didn't put
my heart and soul into this there's no
way I wouldn't be or I am today what is
your food show and that would be
portrayed as a kid show I heard your
time
yeah it's the best show ever and I
think that was all the questions I
wanted to leave with asking you bros for
questions so I don't feel like I just
rival Don about and I really do enjoy
hearing about you brother so first
question are you a boy or a girl a
sacrifice Ian how old are you third
question where you from and fourth
question how long have you been abroad
silence I'll be fun over fun now we can
get to know each other anyway thank you
for watching I hope you enjoyed this
little different type of video or Q&A I
will try to do it this is everything
next week all right
is that a deal not a deal you go when
I'm in the UK will be I'll be more fun
that way anyway this one is I just want
to finish by saying thank you boys for
watching and you bros really do make my
dreams come true so I can't thank you
enough for that anyway we're gonna end
this with a breakfast
doesn't go there what do you know my
computers but that's totally how it
works what is this shop yes yeah